hey everyone it's Michael Altos and
welcome to the order flows market
analysis for Friday August 18 2017 is
part 2 I did one earlier with the first
couple out up until about 9:00 a.m.
Chicago time at then honestly you know
there's a lot of activity in the market
in this you know after 9 a.m.
there's shake up in Trump's advisors and
you know Steve Bennion leaving me
personally I think it's a good thing in
the sense that I think he'll be able to
do more outside of the White House get
inside but you know for all the
volatility this week you know Dow ended
up down not even one percent for the
week gold was kind of lose a little bit
lowers down the opportunity for the week
Ron 1292 bonzer ended up a little change
so you know is it's a nice ending to the
week actually you know not as negative
as everybody hey everyone it's Michael
Altos and welcome to the Oder flows
market analysis for August 18 2017
Friday this is part two of my analysis I
did one earlier up until about 9 a.m. in
the morning this will cover the second
part of trading basically from 9:00 a.m.
onwards it's quite an interesting day
Banyon left Trump's advisors and you
know markets rallied on it the later
sold off but you know for all the
volatility this week the Dow is only
down not even 1% so you know not much
you know I'm you know earlier this week
you're reading all the market's going to
crash a monkey it's going to crash now
I'm reading on Bloomberg all the market
is a great buying opportunity you know
it just kills me these writers they
spend more time writing than they do
trading but anyway that said jump into
it brief disclaimer to this presentation
for educational and informational
purposes only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract are making any type of
investment decision futures trading
contain substantial risk and it's not
for every investor an investor could
potentially lose all in more than the
initial investment risk apples money
that could be lost not jeopardizing one
financial security or lifestyle only
risk capital should be used for trading
only those with sufficient risk capital
should consider trading past performance
is not necessarily indicative of future
results
two of these in this presentation are
the order folds trader software and the
Dhokla scalper the overflows trader is a
volume footprint chart and the Delta
scalper is an additional tool that we
use to help read the order flow okay so
you know after I did the video this
morning I didn't look at the ten range
chart but there was some very
interesting things developing on the ten
range SNP chart that literally like
after I recorded the video uploaded it I
took a look back and you know just
around nine o'clock the interesting
things started happening so what am I
talking about the interesting things
okay here we are and we just make it so
you can see the chart so what do we have
we got nine oh nine o'clock nine oh one
you have the low being it's low being
made here at 24 19 and a half you got a
divergence you got a small positive
Delta it's 24 it's positive you got
that's what's giving you the divergence
next bar you've got the Delta scalper
but more portly you got a bullish ratio
indicating price rejection down here so
again you know I the first video I
showed you on a full range chart you
know ratio divergence I showed you on a
bond arational divergence this one
happened you know as I was recording the
video you know maybe I should have
looked at it but you know what I didn't
but anyway I'm showing it to you now
you've got this ratio and divergence
forming here Delta scalper as well and
you know you got a decent buying
opportunity around four and a half area
24 and a half area did you get a
five-point rally anything big like that
no you know it got up seven and a half
more or less eight I think it was a
seven and three-quarters but mostly just
kind of went sideways did come back in
came back into this area where the delta
scalpers kicked off earlier then it just
sort of went sideways some more some
more came back down to 20 and a quarter
or so he goes that twenty and a half
right here but then this is where things
got very interesting again you know this
is why if you're not using order flow
I'm not saying you got to be using my
chart you know use you know there's a
lot of software out there and personally
I know I prefer my charts because you
know that's what I've been looking at
for how many
years and but again you know you could
see this on a normal footprint chart
this bar right here look at this Delta
13,000 that's massive okay you have to
understand what is massive Delta what is
an average Delta 4000 is you know above
average you know but something around
here 2009 97 3-6 6-2 you know these are
about your average on a 10 range chart
but when you get above 10,000 it's just
like lights out by it or if it was a
negative 13,000 you'd be selling it in
this case you're buying it because it's
just dominated by aggressive buying yes
you have sellers in here yes you do
right because you're not going to have a
buyer without a seller but the
aggressive buyers are over running the
sellers so people are coming in here
selling the out of it thirteen
thousand on the offer side but it's
being scooped up by aggressive buyers
that's very important information again
if you're using a footprint chart you'll
see that and again if you don't know to
look for it then you know that's that's
your problem I guess I mean I talk about
them in these videos you know you keep
it a notebook take notes of things I say
you know things to look for but that's
like lights out just buy it you know and
go for the media at five points and on a
ten range chart so you know if you're
buying it here around what I don't know
what this is twenty eight around here
twenty four twenty eight you know five
points would be like thirty three what
do you do you shoot all the way up
immediately up to thirty five and a half
a little bit later you just you know you
come back in down to around thirty
before you go all the way up to thirty
nine and a half and I'm not saying you'd
be selling it up here at 38 you know for
ten points for me five points is good
enough on this on a ten range chart you
know on a massive Delta number like this
thirteen thousand but as soon as it hits
ten thousand it's just it's time to buy
you don't need to wait for this bar to
close above ten thousand insured
intrabar if it gets above ten thousand
for me that's that sign already but you
know so you had a couple of decent
trading opportunities I mean yeah you
had a very big volatile day yes there
are other opportunities which I'll talk
about later but you know the most
obvious ones again you know this doesn't
take you know knowing advanced
mathematics or anything should
understanding the order flow that's it
right you can see he okay you got your
your divergence right here positive
Delta on the low this green arrow and
you got your ratio afterwards
that's a buy you just buy those okay and
or if it's at a high your cell goes and
when you got a delta scalper coming in
off the low you buy those I mean it's
not you know don't think make things
more complicated then you get another
opportunity right here you know to be
buying it off of this very strong Delta
and you know it put it nice nice rally
all the way up to you know thirty nine
and a half we did come off did come off
later we would we settle think it was
around 25 or so 24 25 in here but okay
now do the other thing this one here
okay so here right I talked about being
above a certain amount right 10 thousand
here you've got minus eleven thousand
right they selling that minus nine
thousand but since it's minus nine
eleven ten thousand rather you don't
need to wait for it to settle you know
you could get short can you get short
yeah if you got short somewhere in this
bar you know twenty nine you know it's
it's earlier enough into the clothes
like this bar here is right going into
the clothes it's not uncommon to see a
lot of volume going through the most
liquid time of the day the most volume
you're going to get is the cash close
okay that's why you see these bars right
ahead of cash close you see minus
fourteen thousand even this one got down
to minus nineteen thousand I'm very
curious to see how this mark is going to
open up on Sunday night you know who
knows what crazy shits going to happen
over the weekend but I'm interested
interested participant to see how it
opens on on Sunday night but again you
know if you're selling it okay don't get
too excited because it's it's you got
massive Delta on cash clothes this one
you know it's 30 minutes for the cash
clothes more or less 20 minutes 30
minutes it's safe it's safe I mean I do
know that you know these people have
massive orders to be executed on the
cash closed sometimes they will start
them early I know that for a fact
but even if you sold this one you know
it did rally up before it sold off so
you still could have got you know a few
points here just off the Delta alone by
itself
okay so let's take a look at the British
Pound this time is the British Pound and
just sort of walk you through it a
little bit since you know 2:00 in the
morning and cover this one in the first
video but so I'll go back to around 3:00
in the morning so okay so you got a nice
little rally going up here you got Delta
scalper giving you a buy you you go and
sell you put go all the way rally up
into new highs god divergents no ratio
then right off the hi leave this Delta
minus 1200 your strongest negative Delta
of the morning delta scalpers giving you
a sell as well so it's telling you you
know this this move up is getting a
little bit weaker 300 200 minus 70 minus
1200 it's lights out gives you the sell
does pull back a little bit before it
sells off again it's it's a delta
scalper sell right off a high which is a
very strong signal I believe my own
personal experience has been that we
sell off you get a delta scalper buy
this one fails then you get another
delta scalper buy right here at 7:20 in
the morning 727 ish you shoot up a
little bit you come up here to a bearish
ratio make this new high then you got a
delta scalper sell so I mean look this
you've gone from you know the Delta
scalper by you rally up here you get a
delta scope or sell you sell off you get
a buy this one fails you know that buy
it's a small rally then you get a delta
scalper sell right here what happens you
know you're talking around the 129 128
98 129 even area and you sell off down
into new lows new those new lows new
those new those and those now you have
the a stack and balance here comes back
up comes right on the heels of the
selling imbalance but you got stacked in
buy stack buying and balance here I was
hoping to get a little bit more of a
movement here it just didn't happen it
just it just failed on you then a little
bit later you know you got your
divergence no ratio it's close though
it's 0.74 I use point six nine nine so
this is borderline at best then you know
you start rallying up again
stacked and balanced here this time it
this one holds a bit better and you
rally rally up into up until the close
so you know just using the Delta scalper
by itself
I'm the Saunders British Pound you know
you give you some very nice trades they
have one loser I think it was but you
know other than that you know I had some
notes this is how it looks on a bar
chart here just you know I mean look at
that yeah buy sell buy that fails
norther buy that works and I sell right
here
you know it's 50 points in the British
Pound right there here's the obligatory
beautiful chart in the Delta scalper
this is on the five years you get
somebody's here early in the morning
around nine o'clock at a nice cell right
up here right off the high again you
know 118 21 and all the way down to 18
where you get that buy that fails on you
another little buy here this one just
sort of Peters out going into the closed
for the day okay me a sec okay here's
another Japanese yen Delta scalper under
the decent charts category you got a
little cell here me everything a nice
buy here debating if it would have
stopped me out for this big move I think
it would have honestly this little body
shoots up over the next couple bars and
it sort of goes nowhere
this one here fails this failed then you
get this decent sell here get a little
buy here going it's a cell that's the
buy then later in the day you get this
nice buy from 45 all the way up to 70 so
you know you suffered a couple of losing
trades but you know the winners take
care of themselves right and that's what
you want to happen okay so follow up on
the bonds remember I'd showed you
earlier this racial divergence here on
the low rallied up to the highs later we
made new highs and we have Delta scalper
coming into this high here then Delta's
copper here that failed
another buy here got a nice Delta
scalper sell here at 10:40 you know
getting shorter around the 156 even area
sells off down to the 24s even lower
into the new lows you hit these loads
what he got again you got a divergence
and a ratio got a single print it's less
volume the second time first times 37
second time is just one you know that's
a sign of price rejection here price
rejection here but you know if you're
buying it you know at 20 and you held it
and holding it to the clothes you're
nicely rewarded you all the way up to 25
26 actually got up to 28 but really you
probably would been no binding somewhere
around the 20 area looking to get out
maybe around 1 o'clock out of that
imagine somewhere around the 24 25 area
okay so this is this is Japanese yen
beautiful thing here in the Delta this
morning this is around 10 in the morning
so you know you've got this little bit
of a rally going I guess you'd call it a
rally from 9196 all the way up to 90 to
14 up here but you know watch this Delta
right 186 142 ten- bar red candle
negative 25 negative 62 so you know
these this five bar structure right here
186 140 210 and the bar turns red but
then red and a negative Delta and a
negative Delta that's assigned to you
know the sign that the aggressive buying
is drying up aggressive selling is
starting to take over so you're not
convinced yet after it's negative Delta
62 then you got negative 83 negative 110
you know and you know you if you're
selling down here it's a bit late but
still there's still enough of this move
left for you to be getting short at you
know ninety one ninety six ninety one
ninety five that area all the way down
into the 80s even even lower down into
the 70s here and then you get another
Delta scalper sell here again what's
this price 9172 that area what happens
is it trades all the way down into the
into the fifties you got Delta scalper
buy what happens with market rallies
back up from you know
58 all the way up into the mid-60s you
know then you get the notices Delta
surge actually right here get the Delta
surge you get start seeing some more
imbalances stacked imbalances here one
two then the market keeps selling off
you get down here
I remember this first time I saw the
stacked this this imbalance on the low
here and all these buying imbalances us
I thought this market could rally off
that unfortunately just had put in a new
low I had to go three ticks lower down
here at 35 and a half before it got the
rally but I was looking for the rally to
start coming in somewhere down here I
didn't expect the new low but even on
this new low you see some trap traders
down there as well and you get a nice
little bounce up here almost immediately
from the from the low up way up to the
mid 50s
the circle around start going sideways
sideways Delta scalper gives nother by
here around the 40 area and you know the
market just shoots up from there but I
was really looking for this rally to
happen right in here right off of this
bar it took one more bar to format a new
low by three ticks before you got the
rally but to me this bar was very
bullish I said but it just had a little
bit left little bit more selling left in
it before it turned around and rallied
now you'll notice on this low you have a
delta 0 that's just coincidence it's
nothing more than sheer luck that it
ended up on 0 so don't read don't don't
think I euro it must mean something no
and at home I studies it all that means
is it's just coincidence that it ended
up Delta of 0 when zeros do happen in
Delta but you know kind of rarely here's
one here's two you know it's just
coincidence nothing more nothing less
don't try to read too much into it but
then again you know from 1218 you got
this nice rally from the 42 area said 42
43 all the way up into the 60s and even
higher you know when you get this Delta
scope or sell like for the clothes and
it just sort of just lower but you know
there was some again you know decent
movements to be had but watch that that
Delta there
where was it here tenzin here forgot
this one right here this swing high here
was very easy to tell by watching the
Delta stronger than stronger than weaker
strong than weak the negative negative
negative and we just sold off quite
nicely from this little swing high right
there I mean that's the beauty of order
flows you could watch the Delta you
could see this developing I'm also time
right the numbers are just going to be
you know your average numbers but
sometimes you know it just follows the
script so to speak you know to the
letter to the number and it just sells
off or a little rally okay just to
follow up on I wanted to charge from the
first video so this is nine eighty seven
tick chart let's take a look how it
looks after nine o'clock you know I
showed you I showed it to you early in
the morning and it it got a sell here by
here or sell here a sell here by here
then it was nine o'clock is sell here by
this is where it was when I finished the
video but again you know I want you to
see the whole day I don't want people
say well you know Mike only showed you
can only showed this part here you
didn't show the rest because you know it
sucks but you know it sucks I still want
to show it to you but does it suck I
don't think so look at this you get a
nice little cell here nice little buy
here not much nice little cell here
and you get a beautiful buy here at ten
twenty ten twenty two again it's around
the twenty four twenty seven area you
shoot up almost immediately up into the
mid-30s come off a bit all the way up to
your highs eventually well you get your
cell ten points later so you're getting
a buy signal here your next sell signals
ten points higher and you're getting
short back up here at 37 you know you're
covering it back down here maybe thirty
one you know these two you struggle one
two three trades you struggle with but
then you get a nice short here at third
and what happens it sells all the way
off down to 25 so you know there were a
lot of points on the table in the SPS
yesterday so I mean honestly I think
that no matter what method of trading
you're using
you should have been able to get
something if you struggled yesterday you
should reassess your trading methods
honestly but you know there's a lot
enough money on the table for everybody
to to get to get something out of the
market yesterday I'm not saying you
would have got you know 20 points there
at least gotten 10 5 10 points easily I
showed you the on the footprint chart
I'm showing you on the Delta scalper and
there's opportunities left and right
there okay so on the video for now this
is uh to learn more about order flow
training go to my website or Flo's calm
subscribe to my youtube channel you know
I'm trying to put out a video a day at
least you know time permitting and you
know to learn more about the Delta
scalper go to Delta scalper comm it's a
lot of good information on my website
and my youtube channel so be sure to
subscribe click the button down there
click the bell if you want to be
notified when I post a new video so
thanks everyone bye-bye